yeah if you feel like someone's
following you you just [__] pull your
hands out like this yeah and you go
[Music]
check this story out it's in
Indianapolis this woman is getting her
mail
she gets approached by dude
who's on a bicycle he stops starts
talking or starts chatting her up in the
middle of this conversation he takes a
gun out and he's like hey I'm gonna Rob
your house
and she goes okay I don't have anything
in my house of value but I can give you
I have about a hundred dollars in tips
from my work it's in the car I'll just
give you that and he goes all right cool
she goes to the car gets the money out
gives it to him he goes do you have a
boyfriend
she's like no
not really I used to and then does this
adjust her bags no not what do you mean
really not really what do you ask I wish
like I'm looking but in this town give
me a break he takes her phone forcibly
adds himself on Facebook what an idiot
no no it gets better no no he's gonna
turn it around he's gonna turn around
right he's gonna turn around right yeah
no then he and he leaves so now she has
the evidence of yeah so then she reports
it and the cops get award to like find
this guy uh but he then he messages her
on Facebook and he's like hey like I
just want you to know I'm not that type
of guy I feel I feel bad for robbing you
you're sorry you're too hot to Rob what
is he gonna do like take her out on a
date with the money honestly honestly so
far so good so far you could feel the
connection there was some kind of a
connection yeah she was like eyeing him
up and down it's like your OfferUp
effect same thing yeah yeah so then uh
this is the clean effect the cops get
that warrant to go arrested wait what
happened on OfferUp
so basically this guy hits me up and
then um
keep eyes my Apple watch and he's
watching by the way
he's commenting right now and uh like 2
A.M same day well technically not the
same day he he messages me he goes
you're the most beautiful woman I've
ever seen that's tight it's a good
opener cool but he was buying that for
his girlfriend right that's right he was
buying it for his girlfriend he was
buying the Apple watch but she's an I'll
go dude you don't know what she's
[__] much wrong
okay really
and you talk to lean he goes oh why do I
have to be with this [__] face I mean
our exchange was like maybe two three
seconds long
that's all you need to know
it was because he like felt the
connection yeah he felt the connection
that you felt oh like what do you guys
hit when you when you handed the iPhone
watch
he like touched and he was like oh he
was like whoa
now I just throw the items
what if you saw a picture of him what if
you saw the picture of him with your
watch and he's going
message through my Apple watch do you
have sweaty wrists he better hope I'm a
better hope he texted you and said yeah
Yeah I broke up with my girlfriend for
you
would you give him a chance no and then
he gives you the Apple watch that he
bought from you
can I ask you this if he did it at like
9 30 maybe would he have more of a
chance yeah at 9 30.
there's just like no do you think he was
cute where does he rank appearance-wise
so yeah and that's the thing too is like
that's always going to be the defining
Factor that's true because you're
attracted to them then he's not a
stalker if it's a brief exchange like
that you could only do that because you
didn't like learn his personality or
something no right exactly yeah right
you're purely judging on 100 I knew his
love language is the second he bought my
watch is there a part of you that goes I
respect the shots though
like I respect the fact that yeah I
respect anybody who like puts them so
then go out with them one time
yeah [__] clean it's just like you got
to be old that's that's the thing too
it's like I don't respect the fact that
he hits me up and he I actively know
that he has a girlfriend yeah but it was
a fling it was a it was like two months
and he probably didn't mean it it feels
like a violent threat wait how useful
how used was the Apple watch no it's
pretty new it was like the newest one
the newest one oh okay yeah it's pretty
serious pretty serious yeah you said
what so my ex-boyfriend gave me that
watch and I sold it dude wait how X is
your boyfriend if it's the newest one oh
um
she's lying oh [__] I told him it was
the newest one but it wasn't sold it for
more money he got it at E3 [__] you
Steve not you [__] okay logical
loophole yeah so uh basically what
happened after this is the cops get beat
red I got her in a line Beat Rick [__]
[__] [__] [__] [__] hey no more why
don't we cry yeah man without we're
supposed to be Unified no more PVP I'm
sorry
they get the warrant to go arrest this
guy and then they fight his location and
he's in the middle of another robbery
[Music]
bucks and then now you know he's like
that's not enough is it another girl no
he's this is like his thing like he just
like keeps robbing girls but I like how
he thinks this is not how he usually is
but he's caught doing what he usually
does yeah dude he better be careful
doing this [__] in Indianapolis man
people carry guns dude like he could
just get [__] Blown Away by somebody
you should go to California they'll let
him out yeah they just keep doing it
we'd love to have you I mean he also
looks scary like this is what he looks
like and he's a big dude and he was
carrying a gun for both of his robberies
yeah so he I mean yeah he looked like a
criminal already he looks like a
criminal already yeah but there's you
know I'm sure he's a sweet he's a good
partner but you know what I know I know
you're not supposed to profile I profile
the [__] out of people that look this
scary riding bicycles oh yeah like if
you're not in bicycle gear I think
you're gonna do something bad I judge
everyone a hundred percent and they have
to earn my trust but is that like a is
that a do you think that's a correct
judgment that I that I look at because
people need bikes okay when when like
women are walking midday during the
neighborhood it's probably safe if guys
are walking midday in the neighborhood
they're probably unemployed and it's not
a safe neighborhood
that's kind of what I think it depends
on how much bicycle gear too because for
me if someone's wearing like the [__]
nylon thing with the helmet on yeah I
hate that guy you have to rob you have
to pull him over with your gun and say
give me all your cash give me your
[__] bike how much is the bike worth
give me your give me your Jamba points
too Honestly though I
if it's a foreign
he's riding a BMX bike
and it doesn't have the tassels you have
to worry oh dude today on the way over
here when I was late on the way over
here I saw a guy riding a bike but he
had a a guitar an electric guitar across
his shoulder and part of me was like is
that [__] up I think he stole that
electric guitar well you don't know he
might just start performing while he's
riding yeah for sure but like why an
electric guitar if he's gonna perform
that's what I'm saying like is he is he
in between gigs is he like is he a
street performer or did he steal that
cyclist yeah I mean he's still that
guitar so in my life he stole it first
until I figure out otherwise that was my
initial re like instinct I was like
that's weird so what's the reason like
because we don't well at least when you
go to like certain neighborhoods why are
there so many like when you see cholos
riding bicycles is that just because
they like bicycles I think they were
raised with bicycles and they're just
it's nostalgic I don't think they can
afford a car all right that's what I was
thinking that's what it is oh yeah I
think it's a good way to get around well
hey what if what if you see it because
that's Jill's mom's neighborhood yeah
yeah because the same thing in in my
neighborhood I grew up with just so many
like trolls like gangster ass dudes
riding bicycles because they just
literally got out of jail yeah they
don't have a license they don't have
they don't have that's the only way to
get around because they don't they have
like a suspended revoked license or
something yeah you tell me if this is
okay a guy riding a bike but then on his
bike he has another bike that I always
think is theft and then he's coming from
the metro station one of the bike racks
no he made this he built this place
he's delivering it's a delivery service
to to sell bikes to people that's what
it is it's the it's the DUI service
where you're like too drunk to ride your
bike he's a dump truck when I see a
cholo with a VCR on a bicycle I was like
oh he's just helping people fix things
dude I was in I was in Hollywood the
other day off of Santa Monica at this
Australian Cafe with smack a guy had his
bike uh parked outside and then he was
inside just like doing his work his bike
wasn't even locked bicycle bicycle yeah
and then a guy with a with the [__]
baseball bat walks up to the window and
Taps on it and goes is that your bike
and then the guy goes yeah that's mine
and he goes all right and he just walks
away
and he was tapping on the glass that's
kind of cool that guy's is he dressed in
a baseball uniform no that would help
that would help yeah
everything it said Fury zombies he's
from the Warriors the Dodgers man
so he was looking to just Rob people
just walking around with a bat but
nobody like it's so it's like a liberal
ass Street and no one cared that's kind
of tired like no one no one in the cafe
care they just went okay is that your
bike yeah it's yours okay I won't touch
him then he's like if it wasn't yours I
would have taken it yeah you just asked
one guy I always see something sash
about dudes that look like this and
they're just on a bicycle with a
baseball bat same thing happens in the
park in um like in Lincoln in Lincoln
Heights when we when we would go roller
skating there we put our stuff down on
the table and never fails a dude without
biking gear on a bicycle just starts
circling to find out when we're far away
from our [__] yeah yeah and he'll just
like keep making passes because there's
usually a bunch of Clues like if he's
like he looks like that but he's like a
clean cut or whatever and then he has
like a thousand dollar BMX bike and
you're like oh he's into this [__] he is
like part of the scene but then he's
like
like it looks like he stole it or he
doesn't look clean like you know there's
like a bunch of clues or even the time
of day are they approaching you in the
middle like the way that I respond at a
gas station some people like go oh can I
have five bucks that my car got strand
or whatever like during the time of day
I react differently too yeah there's so
many different Clues oh yeah if it's
nighttime I'm like [__] off but then I
probably shouldn't say four I think
that's actually a bad sentiment that
people are pushing where they say like
don't be rude like if this guy's biking
up to you and if it's just woman
checking her mail [__] run like don't
be don't worry about being polite yeah
like who the [__] cares like I don't
mind it either if I'm walking and a
woman is there and then she decides not
to walk by me [__] cool with that
yeah that's how she should act I think
politech can get you killed honestly it
works right now it is my ex-girlfriend's
mom was at a mall one time and she
noticed this guy following her she was
very like aware and [__] and then once
she got to the parking garage she just
started running she didn't care about
being polite and this [__] took
off after her yeah and she she's when
she tells the story she's always like I
get in the car I come close the door and
as soon as I hit the lock thing because
it was like an older car as soon as she
hit the lock thing down the handle gets
pulled and that was it it was like that
close holy holy [__] because I'd rather
run and be safe and make a mistake yeah
then then be in a situation then like
like offend someone that you'll never
see someone ever again yeah if you feel
like someone's following you you just
[__] pull your hands out like this
or you just do one of these come any
closer
they know what happens yeah they know
everyone's seen that movie you're gonna
lose your two front teeth brother
[Music]